(vibrant music)
(squeaking)
(lively music)
(Frank laughing) - Very nice.
Hey, what's up?
My name is Frank. I'm a
New York City firefighter.
I work in Ladder 10,
and I'm a Ladder 10 truck chauffeur.
- What's up, man? My name is Ahmed Clark,
I am a seven-year veteran of
the Trenton Fire Department.
- I'm Michael Mianco.
I'm lieutenant in Hook and Ladder Company
for the city of Glen Cove
Volunteer Fire Department.
- [Ahmed] Any time that
there's any kind of emergency
we're typically the
first people who respond.
A large part of our job is
community involvement and engagement.
Just being present, making
real connections with people.
- It's the best job in the world
because helping people is, like,
one of the biggest benefits
you could always, like, have.
- You know, being a fireman
is like my second family.
They're all about taking
care of each other,
and, you know, it's a brotherhood.
Like, we live together, we eat
together, we sleep together.
- We take care of one another
and the things that we have as a unit.
(upbeat music)
- I have three commitments to my people.
- Everybody who clocks
in will also clock out.
Everybody gets a fair shake,
and no one, and I mean no one,
gets left behind when
it comes to skin care.
(chuckling)
- I get facials on the outside,
and I'm not telling the firemen that.
I'd get crushed in the firehouse.
So, I mean the least you tell
them the better off you are
so we're definitely not having
skin-care conversations.
- So I think the interaction
was pretty authentic.
The scene looks like a hotel resort.
I don't know what firehouse that was.
- I don't know, that's not my firehouse.
- Definitely not mine.
- (laughing)
- Hey, everybody, I'm Rob
Lowe from "9-1-1: Lone Star."
I want to thank you
all for all that you do
for our communities, and as a reward
I'm hoping that you enjoy your spa day.
God bless. Use it in health,
safety, and in happiness.
- That's actually really cool.
- I'm all in.
I don't know about him.
(Frank laughs heartily)
- I never been to one.
- It's gonna be quite an experience.
- It's gonna be a different
experience for me.
I never set foot in one.
- I'm only gonna need an hour,
he's gonna need about 12.
- [Michael] I'm gonna need a whole day.
(big band music)
- [Ahmed] We head downtown
to the Four Seasons.
- [Female Receptionist]
Welcome to the spa here at
Four Seasons near downtown.
- Thank you.
- I just have some wellness juices
to get you gentlemen started.
- [Ahmed] They greeted us well.
We were escorted upstairs to the spa area.
- I think these rooms
make me want to floss.
- Do they? (laughing)
- [Ahmed] Just jumped into
a whole different world.
(big band music)
- [Frank] We come into the lounge,
and we have these nice
juicy cheese burgers
with onions on top of it
and the nice French fries.
And, once you see that on the plate,
you know you're in for a great
treat the rest of the day.
I gotta pedicure, and it was amazing.
She filed down my nails
and gave me a foot massage.
It was completely relaxing.
- [Michael] Like, this is my
first time ever having, like,
a real professional massage.
I'm feeling just amazing right now.
The hot rocks, the oils,
the smells, everything.
It was great.
It really made me feel so much better.
- [Ahmed] I think the
massage was life-changing.
She began to do an
oil-infused scalp massage,
which is something I
never experienced before.
- [Frank] You know, I
wasn't born a firemen.
You know, you learn how
to be a fireman, you know.
But, you know, for anybody
it's still scary, you know,
I mean it's real life, you know.
And then you're home, and you
think about your children,
and you want to make it
home at the end of the night
but also you want to
do your job, you know,
and your job is to protect
the people of the city of New York.
- [Ahmed] The fire service, in general,
is no longer just guys
running around with axes.
We literally do almost everything
as far as emergencies are concerned.
I'm a hazardous materials
tech, I am a rescue diver.
We also are an emergency responder.
It is definitely a very stressful job
ff you don't have the proper outlets.
- [Michael] A lot of us
on our jobs, you know,
we forget about ourselves,
and you know, taking care of ourselves
probably should, maybe, almost come first.
'Cause if we don't take care of ourselves,
how we gonna go out and
protect other people?
- [Frank] To me, like, when
you feel good about yourself,
you look good, you feel
good, you just perform better
in anything you do in life, you know.
- [Michael] Running around,
never really having time for yourself
'cause you're always
thinking about somebody else.
You know, it really is nice to
have something done for you.
Taking care of yourself,
pampering yourself a little bit.
- So, thanks, Rob Lowe,
thanks "9-1-1: Lone Star"
for this great opportunity.
- Captain, appreciate it.
- My favorite part today
was getting to know both
of you guys and what you do
- [Ahmed] Aww, that's nice.
- in the fire service...
- [Ahmed] Aww, that's so nice.
- ...in New Jersey
and what you do in the fire
service on Long Island.
- [Michael] Honestly, I'm really blessed
to meet every one of these guys.
They're honestly real good people,
and as silly as it
sounds, they are heroes.
- Don't miss the two-night
premiere of "9-1-1: Lone Star."
- Sunday, January 19.
- Only on Fox.
(light rock music)
(squeaking)